in this video i'm going to show you
exactly how to make realistic landscapes
regardless of what rendering program you
use what's going on guys my name is
david tomich i'm a registered architect
here in western australia and today i'm
going to share with you five resources
that are incredibly powerful to take
your renders from basic boring
landscapes to incredible beautiful
realistic landscapes and gardens so
let's get started with number one which
is one of my personal favorites it is
called
globeplants.com now if you jump on
globeplans.com you're going to find a
variety of incredible plants which are
also specifically tailored to different
climate zones and regions around the
world one of the best things about globe
plants is they actually have australian
native plants in there to select from as
well as a series of different tropical
plants including high poly and low
polygon counts next on the list is
maxtree.org maxtree has over 100
resources that you can download at
varying prices so definitely isn't the
cheapest it definitely isn't free for
everything on max tree it starts
anywhere from that low two digits all
the way up to high three digits so it is
a relatively expensive resource on this
list but it has incredibly unique plants
and trees available on max tree powering
through this list today evermotion.org
is number three not in any particular
order but it is also an incredible
resource not only do you have your
standard trees and plants you also get
shrubs and grass in evermotion so if
you're looking for a resource that's
able to cover everything in the
landscaping sector as well as give you
basically everything you could possibly
imagine in a scene evermotion is an easy
one-stop shop next on the list is
sketchfab.com and i have notoriously and
religiously use this website for all
sorts of different bits and pieces for
my rendering needs now i want to make a
statement right there in that sentence
and it's the simple fact that none of
these resources today are sponsored in
any way so if you're thinking i know
david's just pushing down my throat
whatever he gets paid for i don't get
paid for any of these resources they are
personally incredible in my opinion so
that's why i'm sharing them with you
today but back to the point and topic it
is sketchfab who are able to supply you
with an infinite amount of free
resources as well as paid resources so
if you're looking for some free
resources be it plants shrubs anything
in between sketchfab you're going to
find some lower quality items but you're
going to find some different stuff
compared to what you get generically out
of whatever rendering software you might
be using now this next one is a complete
and utter bonus it does not count to my
five resource recommendations because it
isn't specifically to do with your
landscape however it is to do with the
background of your landscape hdri
skies.com
is by far the best hdri skies available
on internet so if you're looking to make
sure that your background as well as
your landscaping is phenomenal then hdri
skies is an easy place to start and
produce some of the best skies in any
render last but not least this is a
website that can cater to all of your
needs from the lowest quality stuff in
the world to some of the best 3d
rendered models i've ever seen in my
life
genuinely
3dsky.org is the place to find whatever
you are looking for 3d sky not only has
plants and trees and everything in
between it has some of the best rendered
materials so if you're looking for a
brand new tesla model 3 you can find it
on 3d sky either paid or free if you're
looking for a porsche to add into your
renders like you've seen in many of mine
3d sky is exactly where it comes from
whatever it might be that you're looking
for for any category that is the
resource that you should be writing down
right now saving to your favorites and
going back to every single day and
that's it for me guys thanks so much for
watching i'll see you next time